my wife's a drill sergeant she she's
tough she don't mess you know she's this
this big but like so you're the softy in
the family well
you know it's funny because my son said
to me my son's 21 now he's a good kid
you know and uh he says to me
back when he's like 12 he goes dad
i don't want you to be offended but i'm
really scared of mom i'm not really that
scared of you and you know like i
cracked up because it's true like she's
got a step she's got to stand on like a
milk crate to reach him because you know
she's tiny and he's tall but it's true
but you know but she was hard but fair
but loved that see this is the thing
you take any
child
anywhere
from any background
if you love them you nurture them you
teach them and you guide them you have a
successful adult
and see that's the problem in our
society it's not judgmental i'm not
judging anyone
but we need to try harder
as parents
as as siblings as friends
but
especially when when we're blessed with
a child it's like
you you got to put that child first it's
like being a military person or
responder it's not about you anymore now
it's the team
so that little child
is is now the team and you know your
wife or your
significant other you know
like it's not about you anymore and see
that's the problem is people have a hard
time
not making it about them
you know like now it's really weird my
kids are 19 21 and 24 and they hardly
want to hang with me because they're
busy in their life we love each other
they're probably tired of hearing me go
on and you know preach and whatever but
like but but they're adults we we did
pretty much the crux of what we had to
do to to put them into adulthood
and i look back and i go wow i wish i
didn't work so much and i wish but then
i say no but it was okay my wife stayed
home
good lessons good you know just just
ultimately like you said it's love it is
it's the common that love is
the most important ingredient on this
earth and now and that's that's the
problem what's going on right now like
take politics out of it right take
polarizing each other against each other
take all that crap out of it and just
airdrop a bunch of love
right like
like i when i worked on rescue me right
yeah i love those people so much they
were such great we had such a great crew
and they worked so hard you're a
celebrity no no no not at all
if i was i it didn't really it didn't
really work out so good i
went on to being a stage hand that way
no i'm not pretty but uh
they don't want old guys waving waving
by by hairdos but uh but but it was
funny we the crew we became really tight
we had like shoot like 80 90 people on
us on a set right
and you know
the first few episodes everybody's
trying to feel each other out because
you know you work with different crews
different people
this is going back starting in 2004 it
was a different time
and
i love to hug people
because to me a hug
is a true expression of love and caring
you may not know a person a long time
but you say i care about you with a hug
can i can it just a tiny tangent this
was in the midst of kovid when i was in
boston and it was you know masks like
triple masks nobody yeah and when i went
to see joe
here when he's trying to convince me to
move to austin joe rogan yeah yeah and
then well the first time i see him he's
like ah you [ __ ] big ass hug
yeah and people so people probably
looked horrified no it was hugging it
was just
but if you're doing in public now it's
like it's like you committed but that
expression because i was so you forget
how oh yeah how powerful that is that oh
i got some of my buddies i give them a
huge a huge hug and a big sloppy kiss on
their cheek and i mean i cuz i love them
these are my brothers you know but on
this set
i swear to god it got to the point
and i'm not trying to whatever but there
was people that would come up to me for
the daily hug yeah and i said
what are you doing and i said come on
bring it in and i give him the hug and
they said you don't understand it just
makes me feel so good yeah it makes me
feel like you give a crap about me i
really do i said but it touched my heart
that people were seeking me out to get
that hug to start the day yeah and i
remember there was a guy in manhattan he
was selling hugs for like 50 cents and i
think he got arrested right it was just
before covered but like i wouldn't sell
them if but now i'm giving them away
well now i got leukemia i'd be kind of
concerned of getting a covert i mean
yeah but but like i i really think we
need that we need hugging booths like in
each city or each town like because
there's so many people that just want to
know someone gives a [ __ ] about them and
that's the problem it's like
like you know that's what i love about
small little towns like where i am now
in tennessee
and i'm not knocking new york i'm not
knocking big towns but i guess it's
easier to do in a smaller area because
it's just not this massive humanity
but
they'll stop and check on you like
you're out in the road and you know like
i'm cutting and cleaning or whatever
occasionally i'll roll a lawnmower or a
tractor into a ditch because i'm you
know not a farmer too good but uh
it's easier to drive a fire truck in new
york but they literally oh i was worried
i haven't seen you and i'm like no no
i'm okay but they literally like check
on you they're worried about you and i'm
going these people hardly know me but
yet they're so
caring and
and that's the problem like that's what
i love about my life
i spent a lot of time as especially as a
young boy and a lot of time in ireland
at my grandma's farm
and my mom comes from this tiny tiny
little village she's out in the middle
of nowhere and and
the childhood home she grew up and still
my aunt and uncle living and still
i just love it there so much because
everyone waves tennessee's similar they
wave
driving by and like who the hell is that
i just wave you know but my cousin will
point it out i got your third cousin
second removed by you know johnny like
holy shoot i'm related to everyone here
yeah right but like everyone stops to
say hello and how are you
and i have a problem doing that because
my wife goes
people think you're crazy why are you
talking to everybody i said
like i'll literally stop someone and say
how's your day going like i mean i'll
randomly on the sidewalk then it looks a
little nuts but like if i'm buying a cup
of coffee oh that happens here in austin
all the time yeah that's why i love it
here yeah the sidewalk randomly yeah no
it's it's just so nice they they'll say
hi to me i thought they recognized me or
something right they don't give a [ __ ]
who you are they're just being nice
you